hello and good morning it is seven a.m a
sexual predator with a History of
Violence was left free to stalk and kill
a law graduate because of failings by
probation officers Jordan McSweeney had
been released from prison nine days
earlier but was not classified as a
high-risk offender that mistake meant no
urgent action was taken when he broke
the terms of his license and it cost
Zara Alina her life coming up we'll ask
the police and crime Minister Chris
philp what the government is doing to
stop it from happening again it is
Tuesday the 24th of January
an official report reveals the Litany of
errors and missed opportunities by
probation officers that costs Zyra Elena
her life
Hall's standards Watchdog warns strong
ethical values must be woven into every
aspect of government or the Prime
Minister resists calls to sack Nadeem
zahawi over his tax affairs
also ahead seven people are killed in
the second mass shooting in California
in just three days
this is the moment a man wrestles The
Gun from the Monterey Park shooter
preventing more Carnage
I had the belief that I was gonna die
like my life was ending here at that
very moment but
something
something amazing happened in the
miracle actually
Chinese cities report some of their
coldest temperatures since records began
minus 53 degrees was recorded in Moher
we'll hear what it's like to look back
at the Earth from space with the former
NASA astronaut Bruce Melnick
and the wildlife filmmaker Gordon
Buchanan we're here to talk us through
some of his favorite encounters with
creatures both great and small
[Music]
hello and thank you for being with us
the Chief Inspector of probation has
outlined a Litany of errors that left a
sexual predator free to commit murder
when he should have been locked up
Jordan McSweeney stalked and kills the
law graduate Zara Alina just nine days
after being released from prison he had
a history of violence and had broken the
terms of his license but was wrongly
assessed by probation staff as not being
a high risk a crime correspondent Martin
brunt as our top story
on the prowl only a week after being
freed from prison but Jordan McSweeney
had already broken the rules of his
release and should have been back in
jail
probation service blunders left him free
to roam the streets looking for a victim
he chose law graduate Zara Alina in a
terrifying and ruthless attack McSweeney
sexually assaulted her then kicked her
to death the probation service should
have assessed Jordan McSweeney as being
a high risk of serious harm to the
public had they done so the way that his
release from prison was planned and the
controls that were put around him would
have been far tougher and more robust
and there would have been more
opportunities to bring him back to
prison within days of his release
McSweeney had missed probation meetings
he was recalled to prison but not
quickly enough the paperwork was delayed
then police couldn't find him according
to the report mcsweeney's previous
convictions his recent crimes and his
violence in prison were all viewed in
isolation nobody joined the dots if they
had they would have realized he was at
high risk of reoffending
police finally did catch up with
McSweeney the day after he murdered Zara
last week it emerged that Damien Bendel
was another violent criminal poorly
managed by the probation service he went
on to kill three children and his
pregnant partner
in a statement prisons and probation
Minister Damien Hines said we are taking
immediate steps to address the serious
issues raised by the Jordan McSweeney
and Damian Bendel cases this includes
mandatory training to improve risk
assessments implementing new processes
to guarantee the Swift recall of
offenders and we have taken disciplinary
action where appropriate
the probation officers Union blamed the
failings on earlier privatization of
their service and current staff
shortages it urged that Justice
secretary to boost investment
Martin brunt Sky News
now it's 20 past seven this morning
we'll be speaking to the crime and
policing Minister Chris philp about that
report so make sure you stay with us for
that now the standards Watchdog in
Whitehall has warned that strong ethical
values must be woven into every aspect
of the way government bodies operate a
report from the committee on standards
in public life said that people should
be safe to pick up potential issues
before they esculate
now the committee chairman Lord Evans of
Weird Al said we heard that Zero
Tolerance of behavior that does not
align with the values of the
organization is essential for embedding
good practice leaders must be clear that
there is a fine line which when crossed
results in consequences
now the labor party debt Deputy leader
Angela Rayner said that the finding
should be a mark of Shame for the Prime
Minister Rishi Suna she's calling on him
to sack his party chairman Nadeem zahawi
over his tax Affairs Mr sunak said
yesterday there were questions that
needed answering and has ordered an
investigation a government spokesman
said that the government takes propriety
and ethics in public life very seriously
is a Highway
now later on we'll be speaking to the
former head of the Civil Service that's
Lord kerslake about that report that's
in around half an hour's time
well the controversy surrounding the
former Chancellor is still making many
of the front pages this is the Metro's
front page which focuses on the PM
ordering that investigation into Nadeem
zahawi's tax affairs with the headline
Rishi dish the dirt
a story is also on the front of the
financial times their headline reads so
how we fight for political life over tax
scandalous sunak orders ethics review
the eye says that zahawi faces Sac as PM
demands answers
Daily Express has it differently this
morning it has the story of a triple
murderer tricking his way into Britain
by posing as a child Asylum Seeker
and that story is also the front page
lead for the Daily Telegraph
now seven people have been killed in a
second mass shooting in California in
just three days eleven people were
killed in the earlier shooting on
Saturday during a Chinese New Year event
and new pictures are showing the moment
a man wrestled the weapon from the
gunman Brandon says he acted on Instinct
a U.S correspondent Martha Kellner has
this
this is the moment a 24 year old Brandon
Shea wrestles a gun from the man wearing
the beanie hat
he had already shot dead 11 people at a
dance studio 10 minutes away
an astonishing Act of Bravery stopping
him from continuing his Killing Spree at
this second venue there was a moment I
actually froze up because I was I had to
believe that I was going to die like my
life was ending here at that very moment
but
something
something amazing happened in the
miracle actually he he started to uh try
to prep his weapons so he could shoot
everybody but then it came it dawned on
me that this was the moment to disarm
him I could do something here that could
protect everybody and then quickly aim
the gun at him and shouted go away I'm
shoot
get out here go
outside the dance studio where the
massacre took place a moment of
reflection
this predominantly Asian Community is
experiencing the most American of
tragedies
for many this dance floor was an
extended family those killed in their
50s 60s and 70s
the first victim was identified as 65
year old my my nan
Jenny and Selena have been coming here
for years their best friend was shot
dead inside I think maybe he's in the
middle of the dancing and then
you know and then he he was happened to
be in front of the door I think that's
what it is because he he didn't he
passed away right there I cannot even
describe how nice he is how difficult of
the last few days been for you knowing
what's happened here
very difficult I I cannot I try myself
not to think about it but if I think
about it I become very emotional
72 year old who can transfired 42 rounds
officers are investigating whether some
victims were targeted as part of a
domestic dispute
and less than 48 hours later another
mass shooting in California 400 miles up
the coast seven people shot dead on
farmland
67 year old Zhao Chun Lee handed himself
into police
it is a never-ending cycle of gun
violence in America The Grieving
continues Martha countert Sky News
Monterey Park
now the NATO Secretary General Jen
stoltenberg is meeting with the German
defense minister Boris Pistorius Germany
is facing calls from its NATO allies to
donate tanks to Ukraine to help them
resist Russia's Invasion our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins is joining
us now from Berlin good morning to you
nice to have you with us so look the
pressure keeps building on on Berlin to
try and donate tanks to Ukraine what are
we expecting at this meeting
well as you say that ongoing question of
will the Germans free the leopard tanks
or not continues today and in the next
few hours it's going to be focused here
on the German defense Ministry because
it's here that the NATO Chief will meet
the German defense minister and there's
no doubt they're going to be discussing
will Germany be sending any of its
leopard two tanks and will it be
allowing allies to send theirs now there
did seem to be a little bit of movement
about this over the weekend when the
German foreign minister suggested that
if Poland uh asked to send its tanks
that Germany wouldn't stand in the way
but interestingly yesterday when she was
in Brussels she seemed to step back a
little bit from that comment and just
said when she was asked by reporters
again on that that they would work in
conjunction with our lives so we're kind
of in that holding pattern again and I
spoke to the government spokesperson
about this yesterday and said what's
going on what kind of time frames are we
working for will you be giving
permission and what he said was that
they need to take this really seriously
they that obviously looking at how they
can continue to support Ukraine and it's
important to remember that outside the
US Germany is one of the biggest
Financial supporters of Ukraine both in
terms of military and other humanitarian
support so they'll be looking at how
they can support Ukraine but at the same
time he said that they need to balance
their own domestic agenda and the
protection of Germany as well as the
protection of NATO as well so there'll
be those kinds of discussions going on
behind the scenes when I asked him
though about time frame he couldn't
really put a time on that he said
obviously they'd move as quickly as
possible but they'd also need to be
looking at this in depth and this would
have to go before some sort of meeting
of the inner cabinet here at the German
government as well so the pressure
continues we know though Poland has said
if it doesn't get the go-ahead it may
make a coalition and send its tanks
anyway okay Siobhan for now thank you
for that
well let's take a look at some of
today's other headlines now when the
Church of England is calling for a
radical redesign of social care in
Britain the archbishops of Canterbury
and York have proposed a national care
Covenant which asks governments to
commit new funding for social care and
provide more supports to unpaid carers
the government says it's made up to 7.5
billion pounds available over the next
two years to support services
the commons women and equalities
committee says that the government has
missed an opportunity by rejecting its
proposal to trial menopause leave for
women in its response the government
said such a move could turn out to be
counterproductive well the committee
chair Caroline noakes is urging
ministers to reconsider
and to the crown estate which manages
the king's property portfolio has
launched Court proceedings against
Twitter it's accused the social media
firm of failing to pay rent on its
London headquarters which have been
deserted since Mass layoffs began and
the Elon musks last year
well temperatures are still below
freezing in many parts of the country
and the National Grid has decided to
extend its emergency plan to pay
households to use less power for a
second day our Matthew Thompson joins us
now for more on this Matthew good to
have you with us so the it first ran
last night it's running again tonight
this uh idea of paying people to use
less energy but it's been expanded a bit
it has been expanded just like yesterday
only the second time this has ever been
done the National Grid paying customers
to use less energy than they otherwise
would but unlike yesterday it's running
for about an hour and a half so between
half past four and six o'clock this
evening yesterday it only ran for an
hour but like yesterday around a million
households so only those with an energy
uh sorry a smart meter and signed up to
the 26 or so energy companies which are
participating will be paid to use less
energy than they otherwise would now
we're not talking vast fortunes
depending on your supplier it's about
three to six pounds per unit of
electricity a bit of context boiling a
kettle for example only uses about a
quarter of a unit so if you didn't boil
your Kettle you might really only earn a
few Pence but if you would usually run
your tumble dryer for an hour well not
doing that might net you something like
eight pounds depending again on the
supplier so we're not talking fast
fortunes but every little helps and the
National Grid very keen to point as they
did yesterday that the fact that running
this scheme does not mean that the
lights are at risk of going out really
it's more because the system is designed
so that no more electricity is being
taken out than is being put in at any
given moment normally what the grid
might do is increase Supply to tackle
that but this is just another way of
doing it by trying to push down on
demand so once again it's not that the
lights are going to go out this is just
another way of the National Grid
ensuring that there is enough spare
capacity in the system to ensure
continuity of Supply but what they have
done as they did yesterday is they've
instructed three coal-fired power units
two in tracks in North Yorkshire and one
in Nottinghamshire to warm up just in
case they are needed given the bracing
cold temperatures given that wind is not
generating as much as it should in case
they're needed to step in and start
generating Supply okay Matthew for now
appreciate that thank you that's called
fired stations are back on standby as
households in the UK have been used
using more power because of the colds
but even last night's low of minus eight
in some parts of Southern England is
positively balmy compared to what it's
been in China let's bring in our
meteorologist Joanna Robinson who's
joining us now Joanna uh a little bit
warmer when I got up this morning headed
in at around three uh how's it looking
for the next few days
yes well it's a cold start from a few of
us in the South not quite as cold in the
Southeast but you just mentioned there
China minus 53 degrees Celsius that's
the lowest recorded temperature in
modern Chinese history so very low
temperatures there further south across
China opposite conditions we're seeing
you know much higher temperatures there
so we're spread across China of 86
degrees Celsius so that's a huge spread
in temperatures for the country there
but yes we talked about
um in the UK very cold it's currently
minus eight degrees Celsius just down
the road from me in Oxfordshire so a
cold start to the day and it will stay
cold for the next few days in the South
and we mentioned earlier about the wind
yes the lack of wind that we've got at
the moment but we will see a change I
think next week with more changeable
conditions and strengthening winds but
let's take a look at the forecast
foreign
so like I said it's a very cold start in
parts of the South this morning an area
really from Yorkshire Lincolnshire down
into the south west of the country
seeing freezing conditions some fog as
well some dense fog across the east of
Wales and into the West Midlands this
morning which could bring some travel
disruption this morning but elsewhere
malda start double figures in the far
north it the fog will lift to bring some
sunshine in South murky with some patchy
rain further north
well still to come on the program this
morning the shadow foreign secretary
neighbors David Lammy will join us just
after eight
and with the SMP calling on the prime
minister to SAC Nadeem zahawi over his
tax Affairs we'll be speaking to the
party's leader in Westminster Cleveland
or for the government position on this
I'm joined by the crime and policing and
foreign minister Chris philp good
morning good morning nice to have you
with us in the studio
um we're going to come to your brief of
course later on YouTube but at least
start with the situation surrounding him
didn't the deem Sahari mislead which is
unac well I don't know exactly what was
said between the two of them what I do
know is that the Prime Minister has said
there are serious questions to answer he
said that yesterday and as a result of
that he's appointed the independent
advisor on ethics to look into this
properly to get to the bottom of it so
the public can understand exactly what's
going on and uh the Prime Minister can
then respond appropriately so I think
he's acted and the premise has acted
quickly he's acted decisively he is
completely committed as he said publicly
to maintaining ethics and high standards
in public life and his actions here by
appointing the independent ethics
advisor and then initiating this
investigation so quickly demonstrates
that these aren't just words by the
Prime Minister he is acting accordingly
as well so what's changed from last week
I prime minister's questions when he
said that he took nadeem's word well I
think there have been some more some
more information came out over the
weekend some of that was put into the
public domain by Nadim zahawi himself I
think as a result of that information
the Prime Minister has concluded there
are questions that need to be answered
and they need to be investigated
properly and that's why he's input got
the independent uh advisor on ethics to
initiate this investigation that's the
right thing to do so the Prime Minister
didn't know about the investigation into
nazim sahu when he appointed him as as
chairman my understanding is that when
the Prime Minister appointed Nadim
zahawi uh his understanding was there
were no outstanding uh tax issues at
that time and I don't think my
understanding is that he wasn't aware of
the discussions that had taken place uh
previously clearly over the weekend
further things were
disclosed uh publicly which has led the
prime minister to appoint the
independent ethics advisor to
investigate and that is exactly the
right thing to do it shows that the
prime minister is acting exactly as he
said he would to maintain ethics and
standards in public life was he aware of
the penalty that had been levied against
uh Mrs zahawi and I don't believe so but
as I say what we need to do is get these
facts fully investigated uh properly
thoroughly because you and I don't know
frankly exactly what happened and
because people's tax Affairs completely
right yeah and that's why it's it's
really appropriate that the independent
ethics advisor properly looks into this
because you know you and I would be
speculating otherwise
but when Michigan comes into office
promising accountability integrity and
professionalism with this latest scandal
with the situation around Boris Johnson
and Richard Sharp with the second of
London Williamson with the Deputy Prime
Minister under investigation I mean
which part of those three words are
actually being lived up to by this
government well I think actually in the
way you've described that you've sort of
answered your own question because you
know Gavin Williamson is no longer a
minister in government where accusations
were made against Dominic RAV in
relation to uh bullying and in relation
to nazim zahari about tax we should see
like as prime minister has acted quickly
and decisively to set up an independent
investigation so he's done exactly what
you would expect somebody to do who is
committed to maintaining high standards
in public life and I think your sort of
question acknowledge that right he's
done what you would want him to do okay
let's move on to some of the other news
um for this morning and we've seen that
review is going to be held under the
probation service after uh two men Jonah
McSweeney and um and another killer were
allowed out when they shouldn't have
been what's going on in the probation
service well in the case of of Zara
Alina's murder is is absolutely shocking
and the report yesterday shows there
were failings in the probation service
he was out on license he had been
released from prison having committed a
number of offenses including burglary he
then breached his uh license conditions
by for example failing to attend
meetings he should have been recalled
back into prison but he wasn't
um so the probation service are fully
accepted the recommendations made by the
inspector they're changing the way that
they conduct their risk assessments
they're taking into account a wider
range of circumstances I think one of
the individuals in the probation Service
uh responsible for the decision making
is now subject to disciplinary
proceedings in addition to that we're
putting more resources into the
probation service so two and a half
thousand extra probation officers uh
have been hired 155 million pounds extra
per year is being put into it to make
sure these things don't happen again the
probation service managed I think over
200 000 offenders very large number
cases like this are thankfully extremely
rare but when they do happen they are
absolutely heartbreaking the the
um case uh is just heartbreaking
absolutely and that's why we should not
have been out there's nowhere they
should be on last street so how can the
public be confident that there aren't
more people like this out there right
now as like these cases are thankfully
extremely extremely rare but when they
happen they are truly truly
heartbreaking that's why all of the
recommendations made by the inspector
are being adopted and that is why the
disciplinary action is being taken
that's why the risk assessment processes
are being widened it's why the extra
people have been hired two and a half
thousand it's why the extra money is
being put in because we do need to make
sure that the public are kept safe and
this kind of thing doesn't happen again
so extra money going in extra offices
being put forward and wider processes
let's talk about your brief and and the
announcement this this morning about
some new plans for policing
um part of it was announced because of
the shooting of Olivia Pratt Corbell
um you want to try and crack down on
criminal gangs but just at Christmas Eve
another person was shot in Liverpool so
is enough being done in cities like that
where there are high crime rates to try
and make sure that these kind of crimes
don't occur well the rollout of the
clear hold build uh strategy Nationwide
is designed to address these these
organized crime gangs who blight
people's lives we have seen successful
pilot work going on in parts of the
country for example in West Yorkshire uh
we saw when this program was piloted a
57 reduction in burglary a 27 reduction
in drug offenses and actually on
merseyside where it was piloted as well
we saw 420 arrests 11 firearm seizures
and 90 vehicle seizures so we're now
going to roll this out across the
country it is supported of course by all
the extra police officers we're in the
process now of hiring we're going to hit
at I believe we're going to hit
I think we will then we'll have more
police officers uh here in in the
country than we have ever had at any
point in the UK's history and those
extra officers of course will be partly
deployed um against this threat this
organized criminal gang threat we've
seen this this new uh model clear hold
build working in the pilot areas we're
now going to apply it across the country
to keep our streets safe uh these
criminal gangs ruthlessly Target
vulnerable people they're dealing drugs
they're very often committing violent
offenses against each other and against
the public and that's why we need to
clamp down on them and put them where
they belong which is in prison yeah and
I know your short time a couple more
questions before if we can please uh you
will have seen the reports over the
weekend and yesterday in the paper about
a number of children going missing from
home office around hotels in the south
of England what's the government's doing
to find those missing children yeah so I
spoke to my colleague the immigration
Minister and about this uh last night in
preparation for this kind of
conversation nation and so they are
overwhelmingly uh 16 and 17 years old
when you say child you sort of Imagine a
five-year-old but they're mostly 16 and
17. but you're not they're not
diminished
they're not and by the way some of them
are age disputed meaning they're
probably over 18. and they're not
detained to be clear and we're not
detaining them they are they are free to
to come and go
um and in each case where someone has
um gone missing or absconded all of the
usual processes are followed as they
would if any other
um under 18 person goes missing with the
police and with the local Authority and
so that those processes happen have
happened already as a matter of routine
um in each case and they're also on
these sites you know nurses there are
social workers present to make sure they
do get the support some of these
children have been trafficked Mr Phil
yeah so I asked the immigration Minister
this question last night and um he is
not aware of any evidence that anyone
has been
um kidnapped or anything like that if
anyone does have that evidence I would
urge them to like urgently contact the
police or contact Crime Stoppers but my
colleague the immigration minister is
isn't aware of any such evidence but if
anyone has it they should urgently uh
come forward as I say well I'm sure that
those who have it will come forward if
they do have a Mr Phil really love to
talk to you tomorrow thank you very much
for being with us all right now in uh
some other news this morning I just want
to bring you some breaking news that
came in in the last couple of minutes
while speaking to the minister there
public sector borrowing in December was
27.4 billion pounds at the highest
December figure since monthly records
began back in January of 1993 largely
because of a Sharp rise in spending on
energy support schemes and an increase
in debt interest now the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt said that right now we're
helping millions of families with the
cost of living but we must also ensure
that our level of debt is fair for
future Generations he goes on to say
we've already taken some tough decisions
to get debt falling and it's vital that
we stick to this plan so we can halve
inflation this year and get growth going
again creating better paid jobs across
the country
now we're going to speak to opponent's
foreign Ministry soon as it and other
Western allies continue to put pressure
on Germany to allow main battle tanks to
be sent to the war in Ukraine
[Music]
patients waiting several hours in
ambulances and Hospital corridors never
ever seen anything like this before the
NHS is under huge pressure they have
declared a critical incident every bed
in every Bay is full they don't deserve
to be treated like this patients should
be able to rely on a basic level of care
there's not a minimum level of service
any day because they've broken the NHS
looking increasingly difficult to heal
they can't just keep letting this happen
can the NHS survive join the debate on
Sky News
hello there and welcome back our top
stories this morning the probation
Watchdog has said that a series of
failings left a sexual predator able to
stalk and kill the law graduate Zara and
Lena just days after he was released
from jail
the Prime Minister has ordered an
inquiry into Nadine zahari's tax Affairs
but is resisting pressure to sacken as
party chairman
and seven people have been killed in a
mass shooting in California the second
Interstate in just three days
or the policing Minister has told the
program that the Prime Minister acted
quickly and decisively to uphold
standards in public life when he ordered
an inquiry into the conservative party
chairman at the dim sahabi's tax Affairs
Chris philp said it was his
understanding that Richie sunak wasn't
aware of any outstanding issues with Mr
salowy's taxes when he appointed him as
conservative party chairman and he said
he does not believe that the Prime
Minister was aware of any penalty
leveled against Mr zahawi by hmrc
my understanding is that when uh the
Prime Minister appointed Nadeem zahawi
uh his understanding was there were no
outstanding uh tax issues at that time
and I don't think my understanding is
that he wasn't aware of the discussions
that had taken place uh previously
clearly over the weekend further things
were
um disclosed uh publicly which has led
the prime minister to appoint the
independent ethics advisor to
investigate and that is exactly the
right thing to do it shows that the
prime minister is acting exactly as he
said he would to maintain ethics and
standards in public life
on our political correspondent early for
Tesco joins us and we've also got the
cross bench peer reformer head of the
Civil Service Lord curse Lake as well
for his perspective on what's been
happening at Ali first to you I mean you
heard the minister there saying he
wasn't aware of any misleading
statements that have been made by Mrs
zawi towards the Prime Minister yeah I
mean there's definitely still questions
for the dean's Harvey still questions
for the Prime Minister too did Nadine
zahawi mislead the Prime Minister
because as you were saying you know
we've seen a shift in tone from prime
minister's questions last week now the
PM saying there's going to be this
inquiry that the ethics advisor Laurie
Magnus is going to be looking into this
we heard Chris philp uh this morning he
said my understanding is that he wasn't
the Prime Minister aware of discussions
that had taken place previously I mean
that's pretty vague I think the problem
for Richie sunac is a lot of this does
land at Boris Johnson's doorstep we know
of course the issue with BBC chairman as
well that's when Boris Johnson was prime
minister Nadeem zahawi was made
Chancellor under Boris Johnson but we
still have Dominic Robb being looked at
we had Gavin Williamson being sacked
we've got swella braveman back in
cabinet now nadeem's harwi being looked
at as well what labor are saying is that
these are the same old faces the same
old sleeves and the problem I think
virus you see like as well is that even
if this does blow over it adds to the
sense that is this a party that is out
of touch with the public where we are
talking about
potentially a million pound penalty
millions of pounds being paid back to
hmrc being seen as a minor misstep
rishis United needs to show that he can
connect with the public he's a
millionaire his wife's a billionaire a
problem for him is showing that he is in
touch yeah we'll see how it plays out
and just before I come to you well
because like I do want to bring our
viewers we've had cameras outside Nadeem
zahawi's house for the past couple of
days and uh managed to film him on his
uh way out this morning you didn't say
anything but uh take a look and if you
are sensitive to flash photography just
a warning that there is some flash
Photography in this next clip
foreign
sir
well there he is and he didn't so how he
being uh speeded away Ali I mean we
probably didn't expect him to say
anything else if he is going to resign
but he I mean the question will be for
him and for the party he's becoming a
bit of a distraction isn't it yeah it is
becoming a bit of distraction I mean
yeah we're used to seeing MPS going into
cars I think the problem is it feels
slightly familiar to where we were under
Boris Johnson he had ministers coming
out wanting to talk about their brief
but instead having to defend other
ministers and images like that of people
getting in cars in trouble
um that's something that Richard said he
wanted to move away from he was all
about integrity so I think he needs to
show that that's actually happening yeah
there's some real questions I did want
to put to Christopher we had to speak
about Nadine's HOV look as a good
morning let me bring you in now as well
I mean your reaction you will have seen
what Chris Phillips said to me this
morning there are still some questions
to be answered oh most definitely I
think uh Nadeem Sahari is in a pretty
perilous position at the moment I think
there are three big issues each one of
which would justify his resignation
firstly timing uh how did it take so
long to sort this issue and was it right
for it to be sorted when he was
Chancellor the exchequer secondly is
honesty to the Prime Minister it's
pretty clear from your interview with
Chris Phipps that the Prime Minister
wasn't given the full story that alone
would be an issue for me and then
thirdly honestly with the public when
this story first emerged back in July he
denied there was any issue here at all
and said it was a smear
so there's quite a lot of questions to
be answered here and as I say I think
his position is pretty perilous and all
of those things that you lay out there
they would be against the rules of
Ethics that are laid down by standards
right oh completely I mean you would
expect complete transparency with the
Prime Minister how can you trust a
minister if they're not giving you the
full story about their own situation I
think most uh reasonable people would
say sorting out your tax Affairs when
you're in charge of the service that
collects our taxes is not a good look
and thirdly we do now expect uh people
on politicians and others really to be
very very honest and not deny something
is happening when it transparently is
yeah and I suppose in the past few years
we've lost some of that unfortunately I
mean an investigation has been has been
called for
um what does that do for the government
because I mean of course we want to have
it fully cleared up but also it gives a
bit of time and space doesn't it but
allows it to linger well I think the
role of Solari Magnus uh the ethics
advisor is exactly to look at situations
like this and so in that sense it's the
right thing to do I guess the question
is how long is this going to take this
inquiry because whilst it's going on
you've got a minister you've got the
chairman of the conservative party with
their position uh under question and
that's not good either so you might ask
whether you've been better to have said
look there's an issue here let's cut to
the Chase and ask him to resign but I
think it's a reasonable step if he
genuinely thinks there are questions
still that haven't been properly
answered and he wants to get to the
bottom if it's that's what's going on
fair enough but there's a price to be
paid because the story Carries On and
we're talking about it now when you say
f as well I think Ali might have a
question for you all right okay so I'm
interested to ask you about Simon case
the cabinet secretary because he's come
under some fire in the papers the last
couple of days he seems to be the kind
of constant thread the person that's
been there throughout Boris Johnson and
his trust now Rishi do you think he has
questions to answers he been tough
enough I certainly think the role and
Civil Service how much they knew has got
to be part of the uh inquiry I'm
reluctant to form a viewer on it for
obvious reasons partly because I I used
to work with Simon so I have a party pre
at some sense but also I think we do
need to know the fact he's not in a
position to speak out now and defend
what he did or didn't do so let's see
what that inquiry brings and Lookers
look we've had a today a report from the
committee on standards in public life
saying that people in the Civil Service
should feel safe to pick up potential
issues I mean do you think there needs
to be a rethink of the way the Civil
Service works with Government after as
Ali laid out we've seen candle after
Scandal for the past couple of years I
think there is a change needed and I
think a number of people are saying this
now there needs to be more protection
for civil servants who feel things
aren't being done properly I mean
trusting government is absolutely vital
and it's particularly vital when we're
asking the public to do some tough
things as we did during covid as we are
now in terms of having to pay higher
taxes and bear the issues around cost of
living so you've got to trust the
government of acting in your best
interests and I think that means you've
got to have very very high standards
yeah and I do want to go on yeah how
would you do that how do you rebalance
that relationship well I think it's
about being confident that civil service
can have a channel to raise issues and
that they won't be put out in any
position of risk in their jobs if they
do raise issues that's got to be the way
forward here and we've got but in the
end I would say unless the Prime
Minister fundamentally believes in the
importance of this then I think no
amount of changes to the rules or
ultimately change it I think if we're
really honest Boris Johnson had a loose
attachment to some of this I hope Rishi
sunak is different we'll see when he uh
deals with these current inquiries and I
suppose we could also as well and that
could be a see a change of government
would you like to see any incoming
government make promises like you're
saying to try and reform the
relationship yes I would and I think a
conversation should happen as part of
preparing for government if labor wins
to say well what would you do to improve
uh Integrity here what changes do you
want to make to be absolutely sure or
above and beyond reproach on this and
just final thought for you because like
I understand that so Kirsten was looking
for a new Chief of Staff have you ever
considered getting back into it well
it's a really interesting job
um I think personally I'm too old for
that role that'd be silly it needs
someone younger and um
well potentially yes but I think it
needs someone who can work all hours God
sends and that probably isn't me at the
moment probably but you didn't say no
thank you thank you very much all right
thank you guys now the Polish prime
minister says that his government will
ask Berlin for permission to send it
german-built leopard two tanks to
Ukraine Germany's under pressure from
Ukraine and other Western allies to give
the green light which is necessary for
the tanks to be deployed well I'm
pleased to say that I'm joined Now by
Lucas Justina a spokesperson for
Poland's Ministry of Foreign Affairs who
joining us from Warsaw Lucas thank you
very much for being with us this morning
and good morning to you
um all right so first of all where are
we with the tanks here there has been
reports that the Polish government way
will go It Alone with it with a
coalition of of some willing countries
and and send their leopard two tanks to
Ukraine despite uh Germany's saying no
Sunday evening situation changed a
little bit because uh bundes Minister
for foreign affairs
declared in Paris during television
interview that she will not protest
against such
um such gift for the ukrainians uh
polish prime minister and polish
Minister of Foreign Affairs are open to
ask Germans again for for confirmation
on this but we are still waiting for a
wider declaration from Chancellor
Schultz he's mostly the one who opposed
against that gift to Ukraine in last few
days
now Lucas there have been some reports
uh this morning saying that um if
there's already been an agreement on a
number of Tanks to be supplied if
Germany gives consent uh with some
countries opponents involved in the
Coalition of countries can you confirm
that and confirm the number of of tanks
and the countries involved in that
Coalition that's trying to push this
forward
let's be a diplomat I will wait with
this confirmation until there will be
official company but there is a
coalition there are countries who are
ready to do that I mean one of them you
are in this one of them because the
United Kingdom is the country who who
will be probably one of the best and one
of the most important participants of
that Coalition but let's wait there were
too many declarations in last few days
to say numbers and to say who is exactly
in
yeah we know how many tanks are being
requested by uh vladimirinski he wants
some 300 main battle tanks and I guess
the benefit of sending leopards from
Poland is it's it's right there and
obviously Poland is obviously at the
moment a key Ally in terms of training
in in helping to um renew and uh
renovate and and work on any uh
military personnel and equipment that
needs to be fixed so it'd be very
convenient if those Polish tanks were
sent
yes I will also very much
Happy how Britain participate in it and
how Britain supports us uh also in
training and also in making some
important issues for our ukrainians here
in Poland
uh and Lucas finally just just a thought
from you on uh why you think there is
this hesitancy out of Germany obviously
that country has a history
um that uh the current leadership are
very respectful of and I do wonder is
there a is there a sense that Germany's
trying to make sure that it's preparing
its military building up its military
because we know that it's had under
investment before it decides that it's
going to send any of its tanks abroad
maybe that maybe some political issues
like trying not to avoid Russia too much
maybe some rivalry inside European Union
maybe some fears in Germany about
military involvement in Eastern Europe
which has not very good historical
record that's for Germans to know but we
are still waiting for Germans to improve
the leadership in Europe the leadership
they declare and it's no room for
improvement without helping ukrainians
with arms and Facilities like that
okay uh Lucas Justin you have to leave
it there spokesperson for the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs in Poland appreciate
your time this morning thank you
hello there and welcome back now the
archbishops of Canterbury and York have
released their joint reimagining care
commission reports today in the hopes of
changing our approach to care and
support it outlines three key actions
rethink attitudes rebounds roles and
responsibilities and redesign for the
social care system well joining us now
is Dr Anna Dixon chair of the
archbishops commission and who helped
write to this report Dr Dixon thank you
so much for being with us so we've laid
out some of it there just talk to us why
I decided that this report was important
and what you want to see happen well the
archbishops commissioned this report
because I think they felt that this was
an issue that was being neglected that
so over so many years people have
promised politicians have promised to
fix social care and nothing had happened
and so many people we see who need care
and support whether they're adults
living with disability or older people
are just not getting care and support to
live a good life and that's really what
we're saying that we need to rethink
radically our whole approach to care and
support what does that mean rethink
radically
vulnerable people needy people but the
reality is it affects all of us in one
way or another either because we're
caring for a loved one or relative or
because at some point in our lives
there's more of us are living longer we
will need care and so we think it's
important we see care and support as
something that's Universal that affects
all of us no is it a case of money this
always seems to be that there's never
enough funding well previous reports
have started with that question of money
and they've got stuck on money and we've
never moved on so this report was really
starting from a totally different
starting point it was about values about
love about trust and about reimagining
what do we actually want for ourselves
and our loved ones in terms of care and
support
so we haven't actually put a number on
our proposals but we recognize that the
costs are falling somewhere we're all
paying for this at the moment we're
either paying in the burden of care that
we give as family members we're paying
as cell funders people having to sell
their own homes so we are recognizing
that yes we are going to have to spend
more on this but we should do that
together in a fairer way I mean the
report is just that I wonder what kind
of reception you think you're going to
get from those who make these kind of
decisions and you should put a figure on
it because the response to numbers don't
they sometimes well we have been um
talking to government but this isn't
just about government we're proposing a
national care Covenant recognizing that
we have mutual responsibilities it's
about all of us playing our part
national and local government yes but
also the voluntary and Community sector
church and Faith communities and as
families and individuals as well and the
focus is on England if I'm if I'm right
it is yes is that
is there any sense of sort of the way
that we uh and people who live here see
the sort of the generational change the
shift the way that we sort of deal with
older people in this country that needs
to be rethought about yes so I think
underpinning their attitude to care and
support unfortunately is a bit of a
negative view of old age and indeed of
disability and so we are calling that
out we're challenging both the church
but also wider Society to be more
inclusive and Tackle discrimination on
the basis of both age and disability I I
know you don't want this to be about the
politics of it but the church does get
criticized sometimes for getting
involved in politics and if this is
about money it will become an a hairy
political decision is there a concern
about sort of getting involved in this
kind of policy area the church which is
already involved in care and support so
out there across the country communities
are supporting people to live well with
disability holding memory cafes we
visited all sorts of projects where
people are being supported in the
community and I think we see firsthand
in the church the lack of care and
support the lack of support for family
carers and it's a moral issue and so I
think we've want to see the archbishops
showing moral leadership on this issue
as they are doing today do you think
that they still have that position of
moral leadership as you know Church
numbers Decline and people perhaps don't
identify as religious anymore
I think these moral and human issues are
so important and it's really great that
the archbishops are speaking out on this
issue of care and support which for too
long has been neglected and there's been
too little action you mentioned about
sort of other countries they have moved
ahead of us and England has got left
behind so Scotland Wales Northern
Ireland are all reforming we look across
to countries like Germany they brought
in changes to social care back in the
1990s this is long overdue what does
that look like then because just
describe because as you say when we talk
about social care we think about old
people and people with disabilities and
how you might need it but it's often
difficult if you live in this country to
not to see what it could be like what
could it be like for us well I think it
could be that we you know get access to
care and support without a fight at the
moment we heard too many people saying
it's just too difficult too many people
who need care and support adults with
disability are left with nothing and
they end up you know only getting the
very basic support of washing eating
dressing that's not a good life we're
arguing that we need care and support
that enables all of us to live a good
and full life now you'll know that uh
when he was Chancellor the current prime
minister had an idea to try and fix
social Care at least give more money
towards it it was the raising national
insurance tax that fell away during the
leadership imagination is the
conservative party do you want to see
the government bring that tax back for
that funding what we're saying today is
that we definitely need investment in
Social care both in the short term but
in order to deliver this Vision over
perhaps 10 years we will all need to
take a collective responsibility and pay
perhaps more in taxation so yeah so you
you do accept that we all may have to
pay more tax to make sure we fund this
properly yes indeed do you think people
can be happy with that well that's why
we need to have this debate and actually
help people to understand what is care
and support why does it matter and what
do we want for our loved ones and
families and if we can get that across
to recognize this is about helping us
live a good life to do the things we
enjoy with the people that we love then
I hope that people will see that as
something that they will want to and
we're wasting lots of money frankly at
the moment on things like inefficient
inefficient yeah once an investment in
arts and everyone's Futures isn't it all
right Dr Dixon really appreciate your
time thank you so much so much for being
with us now throughout the week here on
Sky News we're focusing on the future of
the NHS and we're holding a special
debate this Thursday on the Health
Service and we want you to be involved
you can scan the QR code that you see on
your screen that's going to bring up an
email form for you to be able to apply
to be part of the audience at the
University Hospital Coventry will be
holding our debate we're asking the
question can the NHS survive you can
also apply by emailing NHS crisis sky.uk
the debate is going to be broadcast this
Thursday as I said at 7 pm here on Sky
News
and two on Thursday Sarah Jamie is going
to be hosting a live phone in show
called NHS you're saying now we want to
hear your experiences of the Health
Service be them good or bad whether it's
getting an appointment with your GP
waiting for an ambulance or surgery or
visiting Annie call us now on 0208
167-2200 and leave us a message to book
your slot